Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David
Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde,
filling in for David today. Tomorrow. Luke Beazley
is going to be hosting the program and then Farron
Cousins will be filling in Wednesday, Thursday
before David makes his triumphant return to the
show on Friday. Let's talk about the economy, the
issue that has plagued President Biden throughout
much of his presidency, especially during the year
2022, was the high inflation rate peaking at 9.1%
in the summer. And of course, the reasons for the
high inflation are numerous. There was the supply
chain issues, the Russian war in Ukraine and the
economic stimulus programs that came in response
to the COVID 19 pandemic. And for the past year,
the Federal Reserve has been steadily hiking
interest rates to cool that inflation number down.
It does indeed appear to be working, as inflation
has been at a steady downtrend for eight or nine
months now, with it currently sitting at around
6%. However, there's still a ways to go before
we get to that 2 to 3% rate that the Fed wants to
see. We've talked in the past about how you
want a little bit of inflation so that people
are incentivized to spend money now rather than
wait to purchase things in the future. Because if
people anticipate that things are going to be more
expensive in the future. They're going to want to
pay for them now. But of course, if the inflation
rate is too high, then people savings get depleted
and things get way too expensive, as we've seen
to some degree over the last year or two. Well,
what will necessarily happen as a result of trying
to tamp down on inflation and the higher interest
rates that come with it? Is the slowing of
job growth since businesses will have less
money to hire new people and as borrowing money
becomes more expensive and that is finally what
we're seeing. It took a long time to get there,
but the latest job numbers from the month of
March 2023 show that we are finally getting to
a cooling down of the number of people getting
hired. It's still an increase, of course, month
to month as the population increases, but the
rate is slowing down now. Job creation slowed
to 236,000 for the month, almost reaching the
level that President Biden said would stabilize
the economy and prices. More Americans joined
the labor force and wage gains fell slightly,
which could help to further cool inflation.
The lower wage gains is yet another necessary
evil to calming down the rate of inflation.
It's one of these unfortunate necessities that is
seen by an economist, as you know what you have
to do to bring about a lower inflation rate.
The unemployment rate currently sits at 3.5%,
which is lower than what we saw under Trump. Lower
than what we saw under President Obama. Lower than
what we saw under President Bush. And given how
Trump would endlessly brag about the economy,
he would love to have seen these numbers during
his tenure. Biden should be doing the exact
same thing because 3.5% is essentially what we
would call full employment. Biden is cautioning,
however, that there is more work to do when it
comes to the economy to bring down high prices
that are squeezing workers and families. Biden
previously stated that monthly job creation
needed to fall to around $150,000 of $150,
150,000 jobs. So there still is a ways to go.
I understand that this is maybe not the most
exciting story, but this comedown from the high
inflation rate we always thought would take some
time. And indeed it has taken some time. It's been
eight or nine months at this point since inflation
has peaked and it was always going to come with
some sacrifices. When it comes to other economic
indicators like jobs numbers slowing down,
like wage growth slowing down, and as these
months go on and job creation cools and as
the inflation rate cools, we're definitely
hearing less and less from Republicans about
the economy overall. Perhaps that's why they're
so focused on these culture war issues these days,
talking about trans people and drag shows and
other topics like that because they just can't
seem to be making. They can't seem to make
salient points when it comes to gas prices
anymore. They can't really talk about the stock
market as that has recovered to some degree. Can't
really talk about inflation since that's long
since peaked. And you know, over the last year,
they've just been talking about nonsense because
they really can't focus on these kitchen tables
effect issues effectively like they were able
to about a year ago. And it's, of course,
impossible to predict where the economy is going
to go next. We don't know if things are going to
have a turn around and we'll reverse course and
go in the opposite direction of where we want to
see things terribly difficult to do, to predict
the economy short to mid-term. But looking at
the data, looking at the trajectories of these
different things. My sense is that by the time the
2024 election rolls around, we could definitely
have inflation under control with job numbers,
maybe not quite as good as they are now, but
still at a very healthy level. The Federal Reserve
will then have the green light to start lowering
interest rates again and things could end up being
in solid shape when it's time for voters to go to
the polls in 2024. And not only is that. Good for
us stakeholders who participate in the American
economy. It can also be good for President
Biden's reelection chances if he indeed decides
to run, and it could make Republicans basically
unable to speak effectively about these kitchen
table issues and will have to resort to talking
about the culture war, whatever their new pet
issue is for the day. So inflation cooling down,
jobs number is cooling down along with it.
And, of course, we'll continue to follow it.